-We're back with Paul Giamatti
"Billions" is on Showtime
Sunday nights.
One of the things
I'm most jealous of your par
on "Billions" is how often
you get to eat
at incredible restaurants.
Has that been
a fun part for you?
-It has been a --
It is a huge part of the show,
and it definitely was
a fun part of it for me,
and it sort of increased
as the show went along.
It's a little bit less so now,
but it became
a real part of the show.
And I went
to all of these places
I had heard of and never been to
and then went
to all of these places
I had never heard of,
and they were really amazing
And, you know, Brian Koppelman
one of the creators of the show,
is a big foodie,
so we were constantly
going to amazing places.
-I imagine it looks wonderful to
be able to eat all of that food,
but as an actor,
are you actually eating
all of that food?
-Well, I am,
because I think that peopl
should actually eat
and look like they're eating
And it bothers me,
'cause, you know, actors
will sort of play with the foo
and do a lot of kind of, like,
you know, kind of fake eating,
because, you know,
you're going to
have to repeat it
and actually eat all the stuff
that you're eating, so I -
But I tend to just say
the hell with it,
and I actually do it.
So I'll end up having to eat
like seven chicken sandwiche
or two or three plates
of poutine.
And we go to these --
But the real problem is more
that it's like
6:00 in the morning
and I'm eating...poutine.
And that's what becomes
really strange.
I'll be eating the finest
mutton chop in New York City
at 7:30 in the morning,
and it's gross.
And it gets cold, and it sit
there, and they try --
It's just weird. It's weird.
-I do appreciate
you eating the real food,
because I can tell you
that I notice --
I was just talking to a friend
of mine about a show
that we both like,
where the main character,
every eating scene,
is pushing food around
and then maybe a solitary pe
on the fork.
That does take us out of it.
-Well, it does.
It takes you out of it.
And it really became
a part of --
It became a big part
of this character, too,
this kind of appetite,
that he was just kind of -
Sort of anxiety eating
and stuff like that, too.
So, you know.
-It is -- We should --
Now I do feel like, address --
I really do hope that all of
these great New York restaurants
that you've eaten with
on the show,
I do hope they return
and find life after this.
Because, you know, I think
one of the great things
about this show is it --
it really shows how New York
has the best restaurants
in the world.
So hopefully they'll retur
in all of their glory.
-Absolutely true. Yep.
-You --
The last time you were on,
we talked about how your son
was not impressed
that you were on "Billions."
-My son is unimpressed with me
in general.
-Just in general.
Now, I mean, yeah, no, he wa
not particularly impressed
with me being on "Billions," no.
My son is -- He's a wonderful --
He's a fantastic kid.
But he's very genuinely cool
and you don't --
You got to earn it from him.
He's -- I swear --
He's like Steve McQueen
or something, my kid.
-Wow.
-He's just --
You know, he doesn't
give it away for free.
He's a wonderful, wonderful kid.
But he's -- he's Steve McQueen
-And, you know, I've actuall
talked to Koppelman about this
You know, the show is like
by as cool of people
as you could want.
I mean,
athletes love "Billions."
You would think
that maybe through them.
But that speaks
to how cool he is,
that he doesn't even care
that cool people like it.
-Steve McQueen. I'm not kidding.
The kid --
The kid is next-level cool
It's like -- He really is.
-You -- You have mentioned tha
he's a fan of "Rick and Morty.
-Yes, he is.
-And then you got to be a voic
on "Rick and Morty."
How did he react
when you gave him this news?
-And I had -- I didn't tell hi
that I had done it,
'cause I thought
this will be a nice surprise
And then it aired.
I actually haven't seen it yet
but he saw it.
And I got a kind of
very kind of low-key,
terse kind of...
"Nice job on 'Rick and Morty.'
-[ Laughs ]
-And I was like --
And I reacted like Steve McQueen
had just pulled me aside.
I was really like,
"Wow! Wow! Really?!
Did you think -- That's so cool!
Really! Wow!"
You know, I got really thrille
that Steve McQueen stopped m
in the kitchen
and been like..."Good job.
Like that. You know --
-You blew it. You can't be tha
thirsty with their praise.
You should have
Steve McQueen'd him back.
-I can't! I mean, how can you --
I can't do that.
I'm not that cool.
He's stone-cold cool, the kid.
He's great.
-So you have not seen
what your character
was animated to look like?
-No. I saw
sort of an early thing,
but I don't even
really remember it.
-Well, we have a photo
we want to show real quick
This is you as the Story Lord.
-Uh-huh.
-I think we sent a text of i
to you, 'cause there's bot
shirt on and shirt off,
and I think they did
pretty well by you.
-[ Laughs ] Oh, yeah, no.
Actually that's interesting.
-Yeah!
-You know, I'm actually --
Wow. The chest is, like, crazy
-Yeah.
-Wow.
-I mean, it really makes you
wish there had been
more shirtless scenes
in "John Adams" because --
-[ Laughs ] There really
should have been.
Were there any in "John Adams"
-I think there were none.
-"I think there were none.
Maybe Jefferson
got a little bit.
-Well, I know
there's, like, the --
You know, there's, like,
the after-dark "John Adams."
-[ Laughs ]
That's right. That's right
The Skinemax "John Adams."
The "Silk Stalkings."
That's actually -- That's funny.
I like the touch of gray
at the temples with that guy
-Yeah, no, it's --
It's a very distinguished man.
-Yes, I can be --
You can be anything.
-You can be anything.
With the power of animation.
Hey. Thank you so much.
Always such a delight
to talk to you, Paul.
Stay healthy
through all of this,
and we hope to see you
in person next time.
-Thank you, sir. Likewise.
See you around. Thank you.
-Paul Giamatti, everyone.
We'll be right back.